royal oak bonjour et merci être en
direct avec nous sur rt france un
nouveau préfet chargé d'une mission
celle de gérer les flux migratoires
c'est une bonne façon de faire face aux
problèmes migratoires justement bon mois
déjà j'ai un peu du mal à comprendre ce
qu'ils essayent de faire il nous parle
de coordonner et d'animer les flux
migratoires en ile-de-france moi je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire qu'à nîmes
et un flux migratoires par ailleurs je
pense que encore une fois c'est une
annonce de communication de gérald
darmanin qui plutôt que de s'attaquer à
ce problème d'essayer de 2,2 de résoudre
et et te proposer des solutions autour
de la question de l'immigration fait de
la poudre aux yeux fait de l'agitation
pourquoi aujourd'hui la question de
l'immigration c'est une question qui est
effectivement importante mais il faut
rappeler certaines choses d'immigration
c'est d'abord une souffrance
personne ne quitte son pays il quitte sa
patrie par gaieté de coeur
le coeur léger de manière heureuse non
c'est toujours contraint et forcé que
les personnes en viennent à l'immigré et
pour cela si on veut effectivement faire
en sorte que ça se passe mieux pour tout
le monde à commencer par les personnes
qui émigrent eh bien il faut régler les
causes de l'émigration et ça le
gouvernement français et gérald darmanin
n'en fut rien puisque il continue à
signer des accords de libre échange qui
désorganise l'économie et et paupérise
les pays les plus en difficulté que la
france continue à être l'un des premiers
marchands d'armes dans le monde et c'est
quand elle alimente un certain nombre de
guerre qui sont l'une des premières
causes de l'immigration et ensuite on
est aujourd'hui la journée
internationale de la terre est bien le
gouvernement et on l'a vue y compris
dans vos reportages précédents et est
aujourd'hui coupable d'inaction
climatique
or on le sait le réchauffement
climatique ça va être 150 millions de
réfugiés d'ici 2050 donc je crois que
cette histoire de deux préfectures de
préfet délégué à la coordination et à
l'animation des des flux en ile de
france c'est plus une blague et est un
nouveau coup de menton du ministre de
l'intérieur que des véritables sûr
lyon aujourd'hui il faut en ile de
france comme ailleurs être en capacité
d'accueillir humainement dignement les
personnes qui se réfugie en france et il
faut d'autre part régler les causes des
migrations si ce monsieur emile à en
place par le préfet l'allemand pour
faire la même chose que ce qu'ils ont
fait le 25 mars dernier place de la
république à paris
c'est à dire sortir des gens en pleine
nuit de danse pour les laisser à la rue
justement quelle mesure préconise la
france a soumises pour faire face à ce
problème de flux migratoires mais
puisque c'est ce que je vous ai juste
avant nous ce qu'on préconise c'est
d'une part à régler les causes rations
pour qu' il n'y ait plus des personnes
qui se sentent obligés de partir de chez
elle pour finir la guerre la famine
il faut avoir une politique qui soit
cohérente une politique de paix d'abord
avec un réinvestissement est venu avec
une sortie de l'otan qui aujourd'hui n'a
absolument plus aucun aucun objectif à
part de temps en temps suivre les
instincts guerriers des états unis donc
il faut rétablir une politique de paix
sortir de l'otan arrêtez les traités des
changes internationaux qui ne font que
vous berries et mettre sur la paille les
pays les plus en difficulté
effectivement créé une l'isère qui
contraint des millions de gens à
l'immigration
et puis il faut affronter le
réchauffement climatique parce que je
les dis mais le climatique va avoir
comme conséquence des millions et des
millions des dizaines de millions de
réfugiés climatiques
ensuite une fois que les personnes
arrivent en france eh bien il faut les
traiter comme des êtres humains il faut
les traiter dignement
il faut éviter d'avoir les images que
vous êtes en train de diffuser en ce
moment c'est à dire des personnes jetés
à la rue en pleine nuit déplacer d'un
endroit à un autre d'un centre de
rétention à un autre sans que jamais
aucune proposition pérenne ne leur soit
offert et ça je pense qu'effectivement
c'est indigne de la france
et malheureusement j'ai peu de doute sur
le fait que ce ministre de ce ministre
ce préfet délégué choisi par gérald
darmanin
et par le préfet l'allemand et ben est
la même et la même politique et les
mêmes pratiques que celle qu'on
connaissait précédemment c'est à dire
oui organisée dans les rues de paris
dans les rues d'ile-de-france une chasse
aux migrants pour faire en sorte que
nous on ne les voit pas qu'il ne prenne
pas trop de place alors que lui il
faudrait il faudrait régler les choses
dignement et par ailleurs il ya aussi un
sujet sur lequel on on peut apporter
solution il faut que l'union européenne
et les pays européens soient en capacité
de se coordonner pour accueillir ce flux
on sait avec le procès avec les leurs le
processus de dublin
ce sont eux qui portent systématiquement
l'ensemble l'ensemble de la charge des
demandeurs d'asile mais c'est pas
possible il faut que en europe on soit
en capacité de se coordonner et puis il
faut aussi être en capacité de voir l
alleud le flux réels dont on parle
puisque souvent on en fait des montagnes
comme s'il était quasiment impossible à
gérer
en 2019 c'est autour de 130 mille
personnes qui ont fait des demandes
d'asile en france
il faut rappeler que pendant ce pour la
des pays comme le liban le pakistan
accueille plus de 1 million de réfugiés
donc je pense qu'il faut raison garder
sur ce sujet traiter les causes et
arrêter de faire de l'agitation et
courir après les tests de marine le pen
comme le fait si bien géré mais non
merci beaucoup en tout cas régna lecoq
d'avoir à répondre à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes orateur de la
france insoumise